Speaker 1: Ever since the FBI raid on Donald
Trump's home in Florida a couple of weeks ago,
we've been following the right wing's attempt
to throw everything at the wall and see what
sticks as it pertains to excuses for the former
president. And they really have tried everything,
right? They've tried saying that the FBI planted
evidence. They tried saying that Trump was
cooperating. So you didn't have to do this. They
tried saying that this is just not how you treat
a former president and this is a political witch
hunt. All of these different excuses. Right. But
now we've got a new one. And it comes to us from
Rudy Giuliani, who, as we know, is facing enough
problems right now because he is the target of
that election fraud lawsuit in Georgia. Rudy went
on Newsmax and made the case that it was totally
fine that Donald Trump had those documents with
him down in Mar a Lago locked away in the basement
because they were just as safe there as they would
have been at a government facility. And that's
exactly why he should be able to get away with
this without any consequences. Let's take a look
at the video of Rudy making a fool of himself.
Speaker 2: And now they want to make him
responsible for having taken classified documents
and preserve the. Really, if
you look at the Espionage Act,
it's not really about taking the documents. It's
about destroying them or hiding them. Or give
them to the enemy. Right. It's not about taking
them and putting them in a place that's roughly
as safe as they were in in the first place.
Speaker 1: Well, to be fair to Rudy Giuliani,
when Hillary Clinton's email scandal was in focus,
he was actually saying the exact same thing. Like
he would go on TV and he would talk about how
the emails stored on a private server. Those
are roughly as safe as they would be if stored
through the proper channels of the government. Oh,
wait. No, he actually he didn't say those things.
Funny how there's a double standard between Donald
Trump and Hillary Clinton on this issue. But
what's funny about this clip is that Rudy
actually debunks himself in real time because
he says that if you look at the Espionage Act,
it's not about taking documents. It's about hiding
them, destroying them or giving them to the enemy.
Well, what exactly is Donald Trump being
investigated for, if not for hiding the
documents? He brought them to Mar a Lago and he
hid them in the basement. So definitely debunking
his own argument there is Rudy Giuliani. And
then we also know that Trump likes to destroy
documents. We've heard stories about him ripping
up documents. We've seen the pictures of him
flashing the documents supposedly 10 to 15 times
and even eating a document, as Omarosa alleges.
But Rudy manages in this clip to be wrong about
something else, too, which is pretty impressive,
because it was only a 32nd clip that I showed you,
which is that he was wrong about the Espionage Act
and what it says. Let's take a look at the
Espionage Act. It says, whoever lawfully having
possession of access to control over or being
entrusted with any document writing code books,
signal book, sketch photograph, photographic,
negative, blueprint plan, map, model, instrument,
appliance or note relating to the national defense
or information relating to the national defense,
which information the possessor has reason to
believe could be used to the injury of the United
States or to the advantage of any foreign nation
willfully communicates, delivers, transmits,
or causes to be communicated, delivered or
transmitted, or attempts to communicate,
deliver, transmit, or cause to be communicated,
delivered, or to transmitted the same to any
person, not entitled to receive it, or
willfully retains the same and fails to
deliver it on demand to the officer or employee
of the United States entitled to receive it. Okay,
so that's some impressively verbose legal jargon
there. But if you cut through the fat, you see
possession of access to or control over defense
information and then also being unwilling to hand
it over to the proper authorities who are entitled
to it. That's a violation of the Espionage Act. So
Rudy would have been better served to read the law
that he was talking about before going on Newsmax
and spewing nonsense about it on their airwaves.
And then finally, how are we to believe that these
documents were safer than they would have been
than at a government facility or just as safe
because why they had a lock on them in the
basement at Mar a Lago? Is that the argument
you want to make? So the staffers at Mar a
Lago, the maintenance people, the custodians,
they could probably get at least around that
area. You best believe they don't have security
clearances. So how is that in any proper way, the
proper handling of documents? It's clearly not.
And then we've also heard about how nonchalant
Trump was when it pertained to sensitive
information at Mar a Lago while he was president,
even making an impromptu situation room on the
patio at Mar a Lago after North Korea tested
a missile launch with guests of the resort
just walking by, able to see exactly what was
being talked about between the president and his
team. And remember, Shinzo Abe, the late former
Japanese prime minister, was also there and he
must have been absolutely shocked by the entire
thing. So all the excuses from the right for Trump
on this have been bad. They seem to be getting
worse, actually. We may at some point have to drop
a formal list of all of the horrible excuses and
rank them from best to worst. And my prediction
is that this latest one from Rudy Giuliani, that
the documents were roughly as safe as they would
have been in a government facility. That has to be
pretty high on the list. All right. We're going to
go to a break now, but we'll be back with much
more of the David Pakman show right after this.